go into the whole history of what the
age of the Age of Heroes what the Age of
Heroes is some material about in the
book but it's it's a long time ago in
that really you know nobody knows much
about it I mean the way today I tried to
reflect it in some of these appendices
and and certainly in the world of Ice
and Fire
the viewpoint of looking back maesters
contemporary masters trying to
reconstruct history from hundreds of
thousands of years of evidence of west
hundreds of thousand years earlier when
it may be little of no written records
may be contradictory records oral
traditions and all that which is
something I don't think a lot of fantasy
does that having fantasy frequently has
these long lived dynasties or histories
and it's just presented to as fact this
is this is what happened in the twenty
three thousand years ago and here it is
and the truth is we don't know what
happened twenty three thousand years ago
we partly know what happened you know
200 years ago anyway we even here in
America you know we have our legends
George Washington and the cherry tree
whole Bunyan and babe the Blue Ox Pecos
Bill you know all of these stories and
our country is like two hundred years
old and yet what's the fact behind them
well sometimes there is no fact behind
them it's it's just history getting
imported or some pleasures and another
defect and I wanted to get that sense
here
the Age of Heroes you know has worked my
characters in it like Brandon the
Builder and land and clever and during
guards grief and there are these great
stories about them but you know who
knows whether any of this ever happened
or what the true story is the maesters
building they're trying to get started
just like you were and I've had some fun
about rain that you plant in the book
you know like the Meister observe
Brandon the Builder evidently you know
he must have lived for like 400 years
and around records I build everything of
significance and clearly that's
ludicrous but it it formulates the you
know George Washington slept here
phenomenon that you that you see where
any artifact gets attached to
Charlemagne or King Arthur I mean
trouble running Lyndon K Martha was
[ __ ] everywhere like seven round
tables and numerous castles and things
like that song trying to indicate the
same thing but anyway we're going to
write the real true history but no no
I'm not you know they were probably just
a bunch of white Westerosi cavemen these
people so you got a second runner
curious when you write about a mythical
creature like a metaphor or basilisk and
if I ever bring bring them on stage
their major way
subscribe or something I I think I had
but what was that almost killed Danny
that was but I think I may bring what we
were known at some point I know I have
unicorns waiting in the wings but
although this is of course you know I
think you can figure out my general
table unusual looking at my dragons and
comparing them with other people's
dragons I like my dragons but my dragons
don't walk they don't affect silver
gears they don't engage in riddling
contests they repeater strats
interaction temperate dragons aren't
they doing a good job on them on TV show
the the scenes would be with the yoga
convoy and the Dragons were pretty
pretty amazing and of course the one in
our support where the dragon fried to
slavery yeah that was so happy